what language issues are particularly
poignant in today's political climate
that they might talk about today
one issue that critical is the right of
people to have their lives community
affairs conducted in their own language
so for example if somes a dictator were
to take over the United States and
produce an edict saying the official
language of the country is Swahili and
that we all have to talk Swahili from
now on and all official documents are in
Swahili and if you want to get a
driver's license you have to ask where
Swahili and so on I think we'd probably
object but that's the actual situation
for example in Haiti so it's not Swahili
it's French and the language the people
speak is a different language creo so
that's a kind of a problem that arises
they there similar problems arise here
we have spanish-speaking communities do
they have a right to conduct their lives
to have elementary school teaching and
the language that the children know and
speak of course they have to be assembly
the general society but these are not
incompatible goals in fact we know very
well that a multilingual environment is
actually stimulating it doesn't impede
improves performance and understanding
and being able to live in your own
language certainly has that effect too
so when I grew up not me personally but
communities that were I was part of the
native language of is Yiddish and they
spoke Yiddish
fine the kids with the school